When I was waiting for Black Panther to come
out, everything had me hyped.
The trailer with a killer soundtrack and Michael
B. Jordan, who I did not know I needed in
my life.
The posters with the whole cast serving looks.
The glowing reviews that all ended with a
resounding “Wakanda Forever.”
Now, we can’t make the job search as fun
as the release of Black Panther.
But we can help you make some eye-catching
promotional materials for yourself, like
a resume and cover letter that will get employers
hyped to hire you.
I’m Evelyn from the Internets.
And this is Crash Course Business: Soft Skills.
[INTRO]
Let’s say you’ve been scrolling through
job boards for days on end.
You’ve found a bunch of decent options…
and then there it is: the perfect gig.
Wouldn’t it be nice if you could just call
and get hired on the spot?
Unfortunately, the job search doesn’t work
like that.
Remember trust?
The hiring process is a way to make sure that
you’re a good fit for a company, and have
the competence, intent, and integrity to do
the job well.
The best way to start gaining that trust and
land yourself an interview is with a resume
that demonstrates your work history and potential.
Sure, like Amy Santiago, you could build
a binder with cascading tabs of all your skills.
And if the job posting asks for a C.V., you
have a bit of extra space.
C.V.s should be about two pages -- unless
you’re in academia, in which case, go wild.
They should list your publications, speaking
engagements, and additional side work.
But a well-tailored resume shouldn’t be
more than a page long.
Don’t try to squeeze in your entire job
history -- just the qualifications that make
you a great fit.
If your life is a movie, the resume is a trailer.
Even though formatting can vary, there’s
a basic structure to a resume.
And you should pick whatever pieces tell the
most cohesive and enticing story.
For structure, many people break up their
resume into experience and education.
If you’ve just graduated or don’t have
much work experience, list education first.
Otherwise, lead with experience.
Grades and standardized test scores show you
were good at school, but a resume should show
you’re good at learning.
List each experience under its own header
with the time you worked there, and summarize
your work in clear, concise bullet points.
A good movie trailer gets people hooked.
Whether you liked the movie or not, The Girl
with a Dragon Tattoo trailer gave me chills.
So your resume should always paint the most
flattering picture of who you are.
If your grades weren’t what you would’ve
liked, you could leave your GPA unlisted.
Or if you’ve been out of school a while,
start with your most recent work experience,
like your latest hosting gig on Crash Course.
Then, list other relevant positions.
You’ll want to describe your previous responsibilities
and achievements concisely, and use keywords
related to the job posting.
Recruiters are busy people.
Sometimes, they only have time to quickly
scan each resume, or they use software that
filters through resumes based on those keywords.
Showcase the important things you accomplished,
not just your basic job description.
Good movie trailers include genre-specific
exciting moments, from a meet-cute to a flashy
action sequence -- so tailor your resume to
the job and make it memorable!
If possible, you can also quantify the impact
you had.
And to save space, try to keep each bullet
point under two lines.
So if the job you’re applying for wants
an ‘independent worker’ who’s a ‘creative
problem solver,’ you could say you “independently
wrote, directed, and hosted over 500 YouTube
videos that involved creative storytelling
and generated over 180,000 subscribers.”
[It’s me, y’all!]
You can showcase non-work-related things that
set you apart in optional sections like volunteer
work, activities, or interests.
But make sure everything is relevant to
what you’re applying for.
Playing a didgeridoo might be impressive,
but it won’t make you seem like a good lawyer.
Under Qualifications or Skills, you can list
specifics that set you apart, like financial
literacy, softwares, or languages.
Avoid broad terms like “communication”
because they won’t help you stand out.
Or meaningless buzzwords, like synergy.
[No one knows what synergy is.
Every businessperson says it.
But WHAT is it?!]
And only include an objective statement, which
states your goals for employment, if the job
posting asks for it.
My objective statement might be: content creator
with 10 years experience looking to make engaging
new media for diverse audiences.
But I probably don’t need to list it, because
it takes up precious real estate.
And honestly, employers know we all have
the same objective: be employed.
Now if a resume is your movie trailer, the
cover letter is your poster.
If you looking for a rom-com, you’ll know
to avoid The Expendables because of the poster
with a skull, guns, biceps, triceps... is, is that a trapezoid? Just
way too much testosterone.
A cover letter is a long-form, descriptive
letter.
But like a good movie poster, it’ll quickly
show you’ve done your research to appeal
to a specific organization.
The content and format of cover letters can
vary depending on the industry, as well as
your own writing style.
We’ve listed a couple resources in the description.
In general, you should go into some detail
about experiences that would make you an especially
good fit for the job, and tie it all back
to why you value this company.
But stay concise.
It’s a letter, not a book!
So, if you’re applying to help organize
a women in media conference, you could talk
about your passion for storytelling and your
dedication to promoting equality, intersectionality,
and of course Black Girl Magic.
Now that you have your trailer and poster,
you need some critical endorsement.
This is where references come in.
You should always have at least 3 references
lined up that you have asked to help you
out, and who will give you a glowing review.
You want that 100% fresh rating on your personal
tomatometer.
They should be professors or previous coworkers,
not your friends and family.
And once you’ve got your endorsements, you
need to set up a few preview screenings.
That’s networking.
One of the most effective ways to find a job
is to be personally referred to someone.
The idea of, “It’s not what you know,
it’s who you know” can be scarily accurate.
But luckily, anyone can build a professional
network with time and effort.
Stay in touch with former managers, teachers,
coworkers, and professors!
And remember to build a strong reputation,
both inside and outside of work.
Now, just like we judge celebrities by what
they’ve said online I’m looking at you,
Kanye - what’s goin’ on?!.
make sure your movie isn’t tarnished by
social media garbage fires.
Just like you’d Google a best friend’s
Tinder date, a potential employer is going
to be checking up on you.
So even if you’re not in the middle of a
job search, make sure to check your profiles
pretty often for red flags.
But that can be tricky, so let’s go to the
Thought Bubble.
Let’s say you went on a fantastic vacation
to Roswell, New Mexico.
You hiked a bit, went on a planetary pub crawl,
and maybe you thought you saw a UFO in the
field by your Airbnb.
You really want to post some trip highlights,
but you’re searching for a job.
What should you share?
Obviously, discriminatory comments about race,
gender, age, or other groups are never okay
[-- on social media… or in life.
Come on, people.]
But beyond that, there are no hard and fast
rules about what is or isn’t appropriate
-- it all depends on the recruiter.
Probably keep any curse words in check.
And it’s better to avoid references to alcohol
or drug use -- so photos of that beer-chugging
contest are out.
Like any written communication, even a tweet
with poor spelling or grammar could knock
your reputation down a few points.
Some positions scrutinize more than others,
so mistakes could haunt you like a “No Ragrets”
tattoo.
It’s also important to be wary of context.
Someone scouting for a top-secret paranormal
project may like your insta-worthy photo of
a possible UFO.
A recruiter for a scientific journal may not.
Plus, the people reading your posts likely
don’t know you.
You can’t always predict how your inside
jokes will look to someone who stumbles across
your feed.
So, double-check what seems appropriate with
a trusted friend.
And remember that just because you’ve
set your profile to private doesn’t mean
that it’s 100% safe.
Like, you could be tagged publicly in friends’
photos or something.
So the safest bet is probably posting a picture
of you hiking in a cute alien t-shirt and
calling it a day.
Thanks, Thought Bubble!
Networking can happen online, like with portfolio
submissions or chatting on social media.
Or it can happen offline… where people
aren’t constantly judging your tweets.
Career fairs are good tools to meet representatives
from lots of companies at once, and talk about
careers face-to-face.
They’re most common at high schools or colleges,
but there are career fairs for people who
are out of school too!
You can also request an informational interview
to talk with someone about a position you
may want to have.
It doesn’t need to be formal.
It can be as simple as asking to grab coffee.
And it’s super important to avoid making
it sound like you’re fishing for a job.
It’s in the name: this interview is for
information.
So ask questions about their company, their
role, what makes them feel fulfilled, and
what concerns you may have about the field.
It’s a great opportunity to get ideas for
your resume, or help you figure out if it’s
even a job you want.
There’s always a chance that internship
with your professor won’t be quite what
you bargained for.
And I know that networking, writing cover
letters, fine-tuning your resume, and scanning
job boards can get a bit overwhelming.
That’s why it’s important to stay organized.
Bullet journal or something!
Keep records of the people you’ve contacted
for informational interviews and who they’ve
referred you to.
Make a spreadsheet with details about where
you’ve applied, and save the job descriptions.
Sometimes, job postings get taken down when
candidates are contacted.
And if you don’t hear back right away, don’t
get discouraged.
It’s really tough out there and can take
over 50 applications to hear back from 1 place.
Take the job search one day at a time, and
set goals.
Your persistence will pay off.
Once you’ve built a great promo package
for yourself, you’ll be sure to find an
audience that wants to see your movie!
I mean... hire you.
I’ve taken the metaphor too far.
So, if you remember nothing else from this
episode, make sure to:
Make a trailer.
Resumes should highlight key experiences that
make you a good candidate.
Create a poster.
Use a cover letter as a snapshot of why you’re
a good fit for a company.
Find your flattering critics.
Build contacts that can speak to your professionalism
and your work habits.
Showcase your work.
Attend career fairs and set up informational
interviews.
Next time, we’ll talk about what happens
after you get your foot through the proverbial
door: the interview.
Crash Course Business sponsored by Google, and it’s made with the help of all
these nice people and Thought Cafe is our
amazing animation team.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like Animal Wonders, where host Jessi
Knudsen Castañeda shares behind-the-scenes
footage of what it's like to care for 80+
exotic animals.
Also, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.